the winner of this tournament gets a
four-day trip to Paris with a plus one
purebred entrepreneur for real for real
for real like documented
[Music]
oh my God there's something really here
actually get John K involved John
morgenson Stern on it and tell everybody
Gary's got another big idea here it is
and give them all the bullet points we
just talked about do that right away
[Music]
thank you
this is such a happy room oh it's
wonderful man how are you good man how
are you good good morning
I really do feel a tremendous sense of
responsibility I genuinely sit here this
morning looking at all of you and my
chemicals and my emotions are I work for
them what I just want to say is thank
you because I think we've all worked
extremely hard this year I genuinely
believe that hard is something we'll
always do because I just know the makeup
of this team there's a lot of people
that roll that way here we've benefited
from this and I know a lot of you have
felt this and I've heard this from a lot
of you especially for the OG's here more
so than in a long time I think we had a
very clear Focus the way I look at
everybody here is the way I look at
leadership in general parenting being a
president we have no room in any shape
or form in any situation to not treat
each other or anybody that we interact
with with anything other than super Glee
joyful deep love optimism rainbows and
[__] unicorns here's why because
that's what I do for you
this is very important to me we are at
our worst when the Delta between how I
treat you is different than how you
treat anybody you interact with
since I don't manage you with fear or
negativity why on Earth would we and by
the way this almost makes me want to cry
the amount of issues we have on this
issue here is quite low when I say this
please let everyone know that it's
almost non-existent
I want it to be zero I love you thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
and you will ultimately have a
tournament in the end and we will have
one RPS champ of the whole room I have
something to add the winner of this
tournament gets a four day trip to Paris
with a plus one
[Applause]
nice win Peter
thank you
for a four-day trip to Paris
with a plus one the glory it is for the
glory I love that it is for the glory I
love you too this means everything
here we go
I just wanted to say thank you I'm
stepping away for a little bit I'm
coming back
you now have a sword at the highest
level with that talk what I mean by that
is that's now your reference point all
year to be on heavy offense
[Music]
I think I lied to myself for a couple of
years and thought that I was more noble
than I was but what I came to learn
often from doing this podcast was that
some kind of insecurity or some kind of
Shame was really the driving force at
the heart of me and as I sit here with
athletes or Israel adesanya the UFC
champion whoever it is you uncover these
stories which at a very young age the
thing that might have invalidated them
when they were younger is now the thing
they're striving to seek validation from
as an adult my circumstances are you
know I think yes in some ways for
example
the system
School took such a [__] on me but what
was different for me is I didn't believe
them
this is this is where self-esteem is an
obsession of mine it was this weird
balance that my mom created between deep
confidence but accountability and truth
and so I watch a lot of people being
driven by hurt
and I can sense that I'm driven by love
I see it in so many of my friends I
always say the two ways to build
something insane is deep deep insecurity
turned into fuel or deep deep deep
levels of confidence turned into fuel
one of the things that came out of my
refinement as you call it and my kind of
maybe I meant just at the start of my
wisdom years yes as I look back on my
perspective on my own Insane luck of
being a very optimistic person in the
worst situations and I wonder I say
Steve is mindset a privilege it's
because you described yourself as being
as happy you've always had this this
drive this motivation is there a risk in
us trying to advise others when they
don't have the same privilege I think
mental content is the ultimate privilege
yeah I have no belief that I'm right I
have no belief that I'm giving advice I
have no belief that anyone listening to
this should do what I'm saying I am
putting info into the system and I'm
hoping that people can extract
something of value for them here's
something right for everyone cut out one
hour of negativity add one hour of
positivity if you're listening right now
and you're like social's such a drag
it's because you're in a drag mindset
and the Algos and the people you follow
are following you you know what my
social looks like [__] sunshine in
the world of the momentum of Darkness
right now sunshine you know why I choose
to fight
for positivity but I refuse to not be
grounded in practicality which is why
I've always thrown curveballs love
everybody it's all awesome [__] eighth
place trophies what Gary what eighth
place trophies lead to entitlement and
fear of losing and it [__] up kids
so like it's kind of that juxtaposition
practical positivity we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest asks a question for the next guest
what do you want
your Tombstone to read about you
he gave more than he took
very clear to me it's been there for a
long time in my head
listen I have a lot of dreams and hopes
for myself we need to teach people
that's okay that doesn't make you bad
that makes you awesome
but if you can balance that with also
giving just a little bit more in
whatever that means I gave more than I
took I believe in that you've certainly
given me much more than you've ever
taken so thank you for that guy I
appreciate you and it's an honor to
spend some time with you thank you
brother
you pull the real stuff
on real talk you're catching us at the
right time we're now six seven years
into this agency if that is going to be
a big barometer for you there's nobody
within the universe of us of what they
can do outside the field and Kendall let
me let me give you the inside game of
what's going on with us so when we
started six years ago I didn't want to
hire any of the big agents I wanted to
create my own culture for me we knew we
were going to eat [__] for a minute you
know because we didn't have it like
we're like you know we could only go on
like yo you know like that kind of [__]
and so we build we build now we're there
last year two picks in the top seven
six top six we had huge free agency now
the [__] that people used to talk about
us like yeah they're good at marketing
but what about football we're over at
hump now
when people really [__] get wind to
what we're actually doing here there's
really no reason to go with somebody
else and so the only reason I'm doing it
is not because I'm the nicest guy on
Earth I'm trying to [__] win out here
most of all on some real [__] talk
from the get I want you on this family
that's what matters that's why I'm here
right this second
[Music]
while we're having this moment I
genuinely genuinely think this is a good
time while we're all together I I'm
wrong too much you need to help me
because this is where I'm trying to
balance conviction and humility we need
to figure out when those moments are
because they're they're profound moments
they're game breaking moments I don't
need the validation I just want us to
win I think some of you know this like I
feel so close to you even if I'm not
talking because I'm so accustomed to
talking through like energy I'm like
really here for you and I can really add
value and more importantly I need you
too we just have a different X Factor we
just do and and it's not me it's us
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all the great things that you have in
your cake same thing with this it's and
not ore
I didn't have a philosophical problem
with college it's when I started reading
a thousand messages a month from people
that were in debt and deeply unhappy and
can't get jobs for seven straight years
I'm like wait a minute there's a problem
here
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I want to go around the entire room one
by one what I want is your observation
from the dead I'm really happy I'm
thankful and grateful I'm really pumped
for tonight I'm so excited to hear all
this because this will help me a little
bit and then we'll talk about the topics
[Music]
if you believe an enormous level and why
is that cool because it's going to help
other people yeah and what we are up to
here is that let there be no confusion
that is what we're actually up to all
the other stuff will be nice fun and
cool that is what I'm interested
[Music]
[Applause]
dailyvee hey just great to be back I
want to get I want to get back on the
horse on this we talked about something
in the leadership off site tonight where
we have the fill of Claude coming back
I get to sit with them
and listen to them and watch them grow
that's like the biggest honor in the
world
so as of today starting on Monday we now
have a chief heart officer
all right and that Chief heart officer
is uh actually here so I think we should
grab our chief heart officer
when you know Gary introduced the name
of the role as she rounded the corner
and just like kind of like raised her
hands in there we were all like cheering
for it just like that moment knowing
when she was back and knowing in the
capacity that she was back in was just
it was really cool we were all just so
happy
so many moments lost in the last two
years of not doing the Vlog so we'll
make a commitment to that really good
day emotional an emotional day which is
fun for me because I love the emotions
of business and I have a deep passion of
reframing what business needs in society
I believe it could be a tremendous
Catalyst of good
I think you can impact so many people I
think
businesses especially that come from a
good intent and grow to be big are
probably the biggest thing that impacts
Society outside of governments and
profound human communicators I feel like
I can do two of those things I know them
who found Communicator that's why you've
gifted me with the luxury of your
attention but I also think I can build
one of the biggest business empires of
all time and I'm going to build it on
kindness and stability and good I'm
excited for people watching this video
right this second
27 years after I'd been gone and
affected by the message and affected by
the perspective I fight for that daily
truly believing that I can leave a
positive mark on the world rest assure I
can't wait in 22 years when everyone's
watching all this [__] because
positivity's having its day and the
blueprint was written it was executed
and it happened long before me nothing I
do is new this is always how it's been
positivity always wins in the end love
always wins at the end people are just
confused but we all know what the score
is the ones of us that were lucky enough
to have it inside of them and I'll
completely and forever fight for it
until my last spread thanks for watching
foreign